ciao dove siamo
cosa ci facciamo qua dentro
[Musica]
berlino si bruciano mondo
mi sa tanto che siamo in un'altra escape
room ma sono finita qua questa volta ora
ti racconto
me ne stavo tranquillo nella mia
cameretta quando all'improvviso e di un
palloncino rosso e ingenuamente deciso
di seguirlo in crisi e così che penso di
essere finita qua in questa nuova escape
room come sempre dobbiamo cercare di
uscire insieme abbiamo risolvere i bar
iniqui e alla fine del video dovrai fare
una scelta molto importante
avrei 4 caselline su cui cliccare dolo
una sarà la soluzione che ci porterà
sani e salvi fuori da queste skype room
la scorso video di escape room del demo
gorgone ha raggiunto i 40 mila mi piace
come promesso ecco a voi un'altra
iscritto russe anche questo video
raggiunto i 40 mila mi piace ci sarà
un'altra iscritto ma ora non perdiamo
tempo
iniziamo a cercare i primi indizi
[Musica]
benvenuti nella mia escape room
riuscirete ad uscire spero proprio di no
dovrete stare molto attenti a tutti gli
indizi
tenete gli occhi bene aperti puoi
risolvere solo gli indovinelli giusti
altrimenti perderai quindi attenti ai
numeri buona sfortuna danny wise cosa
significa puoi risolvere solo di
indovinelli giusti altrimenti perderai
quindi attenti ai numeri denotato ci
sono mai in bilico se c'è qualche
messaggio nascosto come la tenuta questo
è un numero 7
nel biglietto non c'è scritto da quale
numero iniziare però sembro uno penso
che dovremmo iniziare che un numero 1
voi che ne dite
primo indovinello c'è una macchina da
scrivere con delle lettere e un
biglietto
ci sono alcune lettere barrate proviamo
scrivere le lettere non barate s la s
non è barrata quindi scriviamo lata s la
a e barrata quindi la stanziamo ecco la
curva carta quindi non trascriviamo p
vallata r sì la b c'è h barrata p
barrata e comparata n 1 di parrocchia
ecco la parola seven server in inglese
futile fantastico siamo riusciti a
risolvere il primo indovinello
penso che quindi voglia dire che devo
andare
nel numero 7 anzi l'abbiamo incontrato
prima questo qua c'è un telefono o no
cosa vorrei dire questo sembra molto
complicato
guardate vero se qualcosa anche qui
sembrano per le lettere strane se posso
vedere attraverso queste lettere
metterle una sopra l'altra c'è scritto
qualcosa in inglese
qua ci ha scritto the bitch is the
number of scorsa che la frase the dig it
is known brusco che vuol dire il numero
e il numero dei teschi perché amo i
teschi forse qua nell'immagine di prima
poi vedete qualche teschio
quanti sono 1 2 3 4 5
io ho risolto anche il secondo
indovinello cioè il numero 7 quindi ora
dobbiamo cercare il numero 5
c'è una barchetta c'è scritto qualcosa
di strano dentro però il pagliaccio ha
detto che non dobbiamo risolvere gli
indovini limon indicati è meglio che non
cerchiamo di risolvere quelli che non
seguono la numerazione e ora dobbiamo
risolvere il numero 5
questo è il numero se sembra molto
complicato numero un altro il palloncino
è iniziato un numero si dà solo che
allontaniamoci da qui ecco il numero 5
sono due immagini sicuramente la
soluzione un altro volo
analizziamo bene ma ci ha scritto i loft
terry del re è la città natale del
pagliaccio in una statua i palloncini
sono tre forse questo il numero qua nel
braccio si è scritto
9 loser che vuol dire amante o perdente
quasi un numero forse dobbiamo formare
queste cifre di un occhiata alla farmaci
allora ci sono vari palloncini di fare i
colori e ci sono dei numeri scritti
sopra non so se riuscite a vederli 1 2 3
4 5 e 6
forse hanno a che fare con i palloncini
che si sono qua dentro
1 2 3 4 5
no non è possibile
i palloncini qui sono solo 5 ma forse
l'altro palloncino sbagliato perché lui
ha sempre un palloncino rosso con sé ma
marino ma stai dormendo tranquillamente
come fai a dire così calmo e tranquillo
mentre siamo nel game room di un
pagliaccio pazzo da beato te dormi pure
merino se vuoi puoi anche aiutarmi per
noi dormì pure il talloncino qualcuno
palloncino ha smesso di muoversi almeno
non sa cosa voglia dire ora sono sorta
di colore viola c'è scritto qualcosa
come vedete c'è scritto blu
non so se riuscite a vederlo blu questa
fase attiva è il palloncino blu tra
questi due fa meno 72 blu quasi il
numero 3 sopra 3 come il numero di
questi palloncini e so proprio che la
soluzione sia 3
almeno spero quindi vediamo dove numero
tel
che brutto
beh questo non è il numero 3
forse quello laggiù nella porta cosa c'è
scritto qua dentro il maiale come sei
entrata nella mia casa
cosa faccio
ecco
[Musica]
un conato numero 3
ma cosa significa così parlò in cina
piolo forse devo aprire un cassetto
ma che cos'è questa cosa sembra tipo le
lettere come in una tavola ouija o usa
ho un'idea di come si dica o comunque
sembra una di quelle per secondo usare
questo per indicare le lettere
ok ragazzi penso che siamo arrivati
all'indovinello finale
immagino che debba indicare le lettere e
qua ci sono varie lettere con tre numeri
quello che proverò a fare e provo
appoggiare il pagliaccio così lascio che
la mia mano si lasci guidare e vedo
quali lettere indica c
s s e t t o cassetto quindi dobbiamo
aprire un cassetto
forse lì c'è la soluzione finale quale
dei cassetti ci sono 35 e cassetti io
provo ad aprire questo perché è qui che
abbiamo provato l'indovinello numero 3
quindi vediamo stazione qualcosa qua
dentro
ma non c'è niente c'è un foglietto non
scegliere il palloncino sbagliato e
questa la scelta finale dovrete
scegliere voi il palloncino giusto qua
abbiamo un palloncino viola un
palloncino blu vicino rosso per ultimo
il palloncino giallo in base agli
indovinelli che abbiamo risolto
che avete visto dovete scegliere quale
il palloncino giusto
solo uno di questi palloncini si porterà
a uscire da queste skyroom sani e salvi
quindi state molto attenti e scegliete
con prudenza
ora vi appariranno qui 4 caselline su
cui cliccare per scegliere il colore del
palloncino
pensateci molto bene se non siete sicuri
riguardatevi video e stati attenti a
tutti gli indizi e perdete la challenge
non vi preoccupate potete ritornare su
questo video e riprovare un'altra volta
ancora
scegliete la casellina